ecco perfetto cosa fanno ma cosa fanno
ma sono scemi non possono fare tipo la
sveglia di mac pixel che quando mi
sveglio la mattina sento meglio fuori
casa contro di me penso anzi peak allora
che sono rimasti che avevo finito tutta
la storia o quindi non lo sa che se ne
può andare a cagare e invece i ragazzi
ero rimasto che c'è il trivial sì che
sarebbe sarebbero livelli aggiuntivi di
mac pixel con che serietà sei entrato
nella scatola zio sai solo tu in poche
parole ragazzo scoperto non ci sono un
miliardo di libera votanti livelli nuovi
quindi non so se riuscirò a fare i dotti
anzi probabilmente no però fatemi
provare una caso tipo merry christmas
light peak ci salva il natale ragazzi mi
mancava veramente number one mac pixar
lavabo è bello ok questa è la bomba che
per mac bix ricordo a tutti che mcpeak
l'obiettivo di mac pixel
non è questo l'obiettivo di méxes ecco
quello che avete appena visto non è
l'obiettivo
l'obiettivo sarebbe quello di salvare la
giornata e quindi disinnescare bombe ora
come stupito sto bambino e accarezziamo
il bambino no no no non erano
esattamente queste le mie intenzioni
prove comunque sia in questo caso ecco
perché bravo babbo ottima scelta per la
sedia cosa devo fare per salvare la
giornata questo egli opta cresce sempre
uk nei livelli non ho capito perché
prendiamo il pesce lo diamo a a luke
tieni luke prendi questo pesce perfetto
arabe sulla slitta addirittura e così
grande la sla è la madonna che cazzo di
slitta è uno yacht stato l'italia dopo
pri e legali sicuro questo qui bello non
era esattamente il regalo giusto ragazzi
ed ecco intanto ci ritorniamo un treno
prendiamo il rubino il rubino e lo
mettiamo nel fuoco non lo diamo a lui
tieni chiedo regalo è che cazzo ne so
non so riuscito un lupo anche per gli
alieni e natale non ci mancava solo
questo salve devo tirare la corda non fa
una piega già fatta non è vero ma come
come avete potuto notare ragazzi anche
via il sito è va beh certo chiamo fuoco
all'albero ho salvato il natale così
vero
tranquilli ci arriverò pian piano top
rider la bomba proprio ecco la regalo al
bambino viene ingoia già fatta
era giusto così la slitta il più bello
l'altra che la slitta in realtà non c'è
devo solo trovare il regalo giusto credo
può tirare il calcio ma perché ce
l'aveva lui la bomba
potevo andare avanti tutto il tempo
acquistare i regali ma era terra babbo
natale del problema va bene ma siamo di
nuovo a casa senti zio previsto a
minchia di albero infilato nel nell'ano
eco perfetto cosa fanno
ma cosa fanno ma sono scemi ma roba che
ne vale almeno ne va bene senti babbo di
mia non è che devo no vabbè devo mettere
il pesce sulla mi ciò che ho capito non
vi palpate non fate cose disinnescata la
bomba solo per cortesia va bene va bene
lo stesso lei col pesce il permette il
pesce sulla miccia per forza l'unica
roba viene in mente perfetto pesce
arrosto ragazzi volete favorire perche
no vabbè allora stronzo allora non ho
veramente capito
basta cos'ha fatto bravo complimenti
mclips sono difficili si livelli dio mio
devo più cia va bene veramente era così
ma niente non ho però pensavo teatro
pensavo fosse più difficile quello non è
neanche il più difficile questo è il più
difficile cosa devo fare
ti regalo un bambino
va bene grazie di avermi regalato questi
momenti di gioia che è successo ma no ma
come ma cosa ma melo è avanti niente mi
si è fregiato il gioco vinto e miss e
freddato il gioco va bene ma dai ragazzi
veramente familia via neanche a finire i
livelli ma è una gioia sto gioco porca
[ __ ] grazie di avermi regalato
questi momenti di felicità ragazzi
veramente sono contentissimo ma non lo
farò mai più la cosa da ragazzi per ora
un altro paio visto che questi erano
incredibilmente intelligenti non e altre
visto che ci siano dei laici
facciamo questo non so bene che cosa sia
pro bello bellissimo va bene dai
proviamoci valve c'è un bottone rosso
devo schiacciarlo abbi pazienza
schiaccio col piccione mi sono gonfiate
un piccione va bene non era esattamente
così posso farti una domanda ma perché
solo perché e non era giusto valigia
però ci sono arrivato vicino che quindi
devono interagire con lui cos'è sta roba
è la cosa più oscena che io abbia mai
visto prendo questa cosa e la metto
nelle stint ore bene perfetto cosa cazzo
si è gonfiato un canarino e è giusto
pacquiao fuksas e tipo un euro di
amnesia ma questo pd ply questo e
stefano o di amnesia va bene tieni più
di lo riconosci e tu dovresti prenderlo
va bene lo appoggio qua è grande più di
pai complimenti per per lei per
incredibile azione non è riuscito a fare
un cazzo proprio robert downey junior e
lui in queste situazioni sono sempre che
cosa fare ragazzi hanno no pisciato per
una volta nella vita mi sono buttato nel
fuoco e non ho pisciato fantasy vote for
president botta al presidente sono io
devo fare un discorso beppe effetto
dovevi fissare nel livello di prima zio
non in questo però va bene
la bomba la bomba nel piccione dentro e
piccione sulpicio nord era dentro è
giusto era giusto giusto va bene tanto
ho preso il volo
va bene lo stesso perché sarà allora
credo lo metto nel bar e sul barile
ho tirato un calcio al bar io sono un
genio senti robert downlad grazie
ma cosa fanno mi stanno allo stand ma
non va bene la birra la birra è l'unica
allora o la do a lui o la mettono il
furgoncino la metto nel furgoncino
perfetto guida da ubriachi è capitato
non sa non si è mosso di un centimetro
quello davanti va bene cosa fare qua dio
mio dopo parla con lui è perfetto ma
stavano allestendo dei wurstel malayalam
ad ora quanto fa schifo
va bene bravo robert downey j
disinnescato tutto auto ford per questo
non l'ho capita ragazzi vi giuro in
tuffo nel pubblico va bene ok altro che
donald trump
minchia che presidente mac peak a dare a
lui la birra per forza è l'unica che
rimane cosa sto fatto che li sto
succhiando le tette che non ha l'età ma
cosa succede e ho vinto a o come è
possibile questo ho anche vinto nei
ragazzi l'ultimo livello è rimasto
colori più di pie è impossibile quello
di pd poi non l'ho capito dopo alla con
lui direttamente
sto ficcato un calcio cosa devo fare te
ne sei accorta adesso bravo non è
esattamente così che si disinnesca una
bomba zero per fa eco già così è meglio
era giusto bravo periodi ce l'hai fatta
no vabbè raga quest'asta che questi sono
stati livelli più belli in assoluto di
mcqueen da quando l'ho giocato questi
livelli migliori complimenti per il 10
che veramente figo tanto non sono
neanche finiti tutti
fatemi sapere ragazzi se volete altri
dlc sennò concludo qua è viva la vita
che ho convenuto che l'episodio ragazzi
video è cresciuto ragazzi consente un
certo argomento è un mi piace a capace
di facebook come di ottenere iscrizione
seno se non si schiantavano provino
belle ragazze
u